[Music]
[Applause]
hello Internet welcome to film theory
where today can we just stop to
appreciate what a great year 2018 was no
not for me for spider-man his ps4 game
crashed and was nearly game of a year
venom was way more enjoyable than most
people expected and earned nearly a
billion dollars to the spider verse was
literally the best animated movie that I
have seen in years I mean sure he got
dusted out of existence and all that so
that was a bit of a low point but still
pretty solid year on the whole and sure
we may have lost one Spidey press f to
pay respects but heck spider-verse gave
us another 6 to root for they're
multiplying like flies or spiders I
guess you know what else gave us though
an incredible tribute to the Sam Raimi
spider-man trilogy the one that
redefined what superhero movies were in
their darkest days the trilogy
responsible for the superhero
Renaissance the movies that did the
Thanos snap 17 years before it became a
spy see me mature those references at
the beginning of into the spider verse
were just that references to those past
movies this Peter Parker is not the same
one as the one from those older movies
but it did give me eager to go back and
revisit that original trilogy for those
of you who haven't seen these classics
in some time you know the basic premise
bobblehead Tobey Maguire gets himself
bitten by a genetically altered spider
great power great responsibility blah
blah blah your standard Spider Man but
upon re-watching them there was one
mystery that was never explained in
movies one that has remained unsolved
for the last 17 years and a mystery that
today I think I can finally answer you
see in spider-man 2 largely considered
to be one of the best superhero movies
of all time here Parker loses his powers
they just stopped working no explanation
no nothing just pooping out at the times
that he needs them the most good
question Peter that's what I intend to
answer today taking this as a sign Peter
briefly gives up the masks to focus on
his personal life later when the threat
of the super-powerful Doc Ock emerges
Spidey's dragged back onto the scene and
wouldn't you know it his powers just
conveniently come back the moment that
he needs them of course all this is
probably just for plot convenience but
you know how I roll if there's an
explanation that goes beyond well it was
important to the theme of the movie that
I'm gonna find it and I think I can I
believe that there is a legitimate
scientific explanation for this
seemingly random plot thread in
spider-man 2 one that not only fills the
narrative gap and gives us greater
insight into the movies themes but also
gives us a bit more information on the
nature of Peters Spider abilities so to
truly understand what's happening we
have to first rewind to spider-man 1 so
in the first movie running parallel to
Peters Spider puberty is the story of
Norman Osborn his best friend's father
who does some sciencing on himself to
gain laboratory induced superpowers with
just a dollop of madness
as the newly-born Green Goblin Norman
does all the usual villain stuff menace
New York turned people into spooky scary
skeletons dressed as an old woman and
star in terrible Broadway musicals
oh man the stories I could tell you
about that show and yes that character
with the inflatable t-rex coming out of
his chest is the lizard give that man a
Tony anyway the film comes to a dramatic
climax when Norman drops both the
tramcar and Mary Jane off the Roosevelt
Island Bridge Spidey
manages to save a bowl get dunked on
Andrew Garfield but in the course of the
final battle ends up killing Norman
unsurprisingly this takes a mental toll
on Peter
after Norman's funeral he rejects the
advances of Mary Jane all I wanted was
to tell her how much I loved her and
listens to his best friend Harry swear
vengeance upon spider-man I swear on my
father's grave spider-man will pay it's
shortly after that that we see Peters
powers start to fail so looking at the
events of the first movie and how they
impact Peter in the second it's my
theory that Peters power loss is
directly tied to him suffering from
post-traumatic stress disorder or PTSD
let's look at the facts the anxiety and
depression Association of America or
adaa for short lays out four categories
of diagnostic criteria for PTSD and
Peter Parker in spider-man 2 qualifies
in each and every one the first set of
criteria relate to the trauma itself to
pass diagnosis in this category a
patient needs to have gone through one
of the following either directly
experiencing a traumatic event
themselves witnessing in person a
traumatic event or learning about
traumatic events occurring to a close
family member
Peter doesn't just hit one of these he
hits all three in the first movie Peter
in a matter of months experiences two
indescribably traumatic events both of
which involved the death of father
figures first Uncle Ben and then Norman
Osborn a man who claims
father to you and not only to Bultman
died and not only does he witness both
of those deaths but they are both dead
because of the action or inaction of
Peter he doesn't stop the robber which
directly leads to Sandman shooting Uncle
Ben and after some brutal psychological
warfare from Norman the Goblin killed I
have nothing to do with it don't don't
let him take me again protect me
spider-man
jumping over the glider finishes off his
other of their father and all of this is
without even mentioning his childhood
love getting kidnapped because of her
association with Peter it's pretty much
unquestionable that Peter has every
reason to be suffering some level of
PTSD but is he really well to know for
sure we have to move on to the second
category of criteria which looks at any
lingering psychological effects of the
trauma and whether memories of it are
intruding into everyday life of the
following patients must be experiencing
at least one to be diagnosed as
suffering from PTSD that list includes
unwanted memories of the event
interrupting the day having dreams
related to the trauma psychological
distress when exposed to cues that
reminds you of the event or
physiological reactions to those same
cues throughout spider-man 2 we see
memories of Uncle Ben intruding into
Peters everyday life ends oft-repeated
mantra with great power comes great
responsibility drives Peter until he
ultimately tells his uncle and can't
live your dreams we also know that Peter
is having difficulty sleeping he's
suffering from repeated dreams of these
traumatic events as he reports to his
doctor you say you can't sleep and as
dr. Conner says whoa is a parings Austin
in short Peter checks off each and every
one of these qualifiers and remember
only one is necessary for a diagnosis of
PTSD
the third criteria required for an
official diagnosis looks at the traumas
effects on a patient's emotional life
and self-identity of the massive list
that you see on screen right now only
two are required to move into the final
stages of diagnosis but Peter checks off
a solid six eighth sinister six if you
will if by sinister six were replacing
team man
sure with persistent feelings of
detachment well the first two negative
beliefs about the world and blaming
yourself for the trauma arc disorder
okay
absolutely hundred percent true in
Peters case there's no doubt that he's
isolating himself from the rest of the
world as both MJ and Harry complain
about how hard it's been to see Peters
where he been powered our internal comms
he's self sabotaging at his job we're
looking for you all morning wanted to
put your phone bill struggling to pursue
the activities in life that he wants to
enjoy or were you headed Parker to your
class my class is over and slowly
eroding the most important relationship
in his life do you love me
missing Mary Jane's performances in her
new play and when he sees her pulling
away into the arms of other people would
you know it but that's when his powers
truly start to falter the powers appear
to be tied to Peter's mental health but
to know for sure we have to move on to
the final diagnostic category changes in
arousal that sort of arousal the way you
react to stimuli in the world around you
and once again in this final category
Pete checks practically every item off
the list problems with concentration
problems with sleep easy to startle
unlike the first film spider-man becomes
far more hyper vigilant in the second
movie staying up all night listening to
the police radio just hoping for
something to come up but where this
theory really shines is in explaining
why Peters powers come back in the movie
they just sort of reappear Mary Jane
gets kidnapped boom they're back it is
never addressed but it can't just be
Peter reacting heroically in the moment
he's already done that with a child
trapped in a burning building earlier in
the movie and his powers didn't come
back then no there's something deeper
here something more psychological it
plays you see well it's not perfect and
certainly not clinical heater does
manage to give himself some rudimentary
PTSD therapy in the movie after some
advice from a very chill doctor most of
a choice Peter gives up his costume and
starts focusing on his normal life again
he gets his job under control he's back
to his studies full force
Jiri engages with his friends again
seeing Mary James play reconnecting with
Aunt May
even reaching out to his neighbor in a
beep lot romance that you think is going
somewhere but then gets totally
forgotten about despite her being
totally available totally into Peter and
totally making mean chocolate cake
hashtag justice for a neighbor girl this
behavior on the part of Peter Parker
correlates to the type of work that
you'd be doing in IPT or interpersonal
psychotherapy which specifically has the
patient resolving lingering issues with
people around them in order to get more
control over their life in order to
attain a support network and ultimately
come to handle their past trauma through
these interactions in the movie Peter is
forced to confront some major questions
about his relationship with Uncle Ben
and his behaviors as spider-man which in
turn helps him come to terms with both
Ben and Norman's deaths mix all of that
in with a healthy amount of outdoor
exercise and an overall healthier
lifestyle both of which are regular
recommendations for anyone struggling
with a mental health disorder and Peter
has really done some heroic work only
this time not for the city of New York
but for himself finally after all these
years why Peters powers disappear makes
sense he's dealing with the impact of
emotional trauma trauma that he never
had the chance to properly address and
deal with in his life when he was having
to double a spider-man the powers only
return when he's able to step back give
himself the self care that he needs and
help himself before he reaches out to
continue helping others the saddest
thing about this is that it's never
explicitly addressed in the film that
spider-man in addition to serving as a
role model of physical strength could
have also been shown as a role model of
psychological strength of living with
and handling not just goblins and demons
out the real world but the even more
dangerous and seemingly unstoppable ones
that lived inside his own
and at the end of the day this theory
just goes to show that everyone
including superheroes have their own
issues and that battling against
depression or the effects of trauma not
be as visually exciting as a battle
against tentacle doctor over here but
it's a battle that is far more real far
more scary and far more important than
any of the ones that you see happen in
spider-man 2 and that sometimes the most
maroa k-- action you can do is taking
the time to rescue yourself before you
try rescuing someone else and with app
there are no more mysteries left in the
Sam Raimi trilogy well except for how a
woman born in Brooklyn has a British
accent its water over the dam or under
the bridge or wherever you like it I'm
on to you and me but hey that's just a
theory
Oh film theory and cut